hey guys it's Greg as I'm filming this
it is 816 a.m. I tried going to sleep
and did not succeed you're catching me
on an all-nighter right now I've been
pretty busy I was a mega movie get
together on screen junkies with Andre
black comedy nerd black nerd comedy and
then ID is 4/20 night and and I ended up
just watching friends and I was awake
and just I started reading so listening
to clean a little bit feel pretty good
though so I thought you know what now is
a better time than ever to catch up on
some trailers Jason Bourne official
trailer number one I haven't seen the
Bourne movies in a long time I was
finally I'm like rewatching them but I
wanted to like watch it with someone who
hasn't seen the Bourne movies yet so I'd
like to show them all three that way I
live I carry asleep through them I love
Matt do you know what I was doing the
other day
this was last night I was watching all
the videos of that [ __ ] feud between
Matt Damon and Jimmy Kimmel I love Matt
Damon he's so funny
he's such a funny guy but he's a total
badasses Jason Bourne yeah and he I'm
I'm so okay what sucks is Jeremy Renner
he's [ __ ] awesome he's a cool dude
for sure and the movie though just
wasn't you know as up to par as as
people say I haven't actually seen it
myself on being that guy right now but
hey you know I'm just gonna maybe skip
past that one and watch Jason Bourne
here we go Matt Damon
yeah okay thanks for the warmup I know
who I am
we are finished with you you're no
longer with yourself remembering
everything doesn't mean you know
everything
oh dude overborne tell me sweet music oh
oh he's back at it Jesus Christ that's
Jason Bourne
oh no [ __ ] way Tommy Lee Jones
there's a demonstration in front of the
Greek parliament building
they tracked you we got a move
there you go nany
Oh motorcycle oh [ __ ] these same things
he knows things what if he's not coming
for us what if it's something else I
volunteered because a lie
this is Jason Bourne I never talk 32
kills people are safer because of what
you can
oh [ __ ]
Oh oh my god got a lot of money everyone
find any piece you know till you admit
to yourself who you really are love back
wonder what it's really about oh my god
oh my god I was like I love like the
Bourne movies are so first off I don't
know how it became like Paul green
grasses franchise but doug liman he did
the first one and he started this off
and he did a great job with it and paul
greengrass did make you know like a more
defined version and style so I actually
get why Paul Greengrass took over
however I'm watching it now I'm like I
feel like the director has also evolved
as well with you know Jason Bourne it
doesn't look like they're trying to do
something where it's like we got to make
it look like the last couple Bourne
movies you know it's been many years
since we've done them instead of doing
that it looks different like the
cinematography of it the way everything
feels it's not as crazy handle at least
for most of it like the action looks
rather clear
just the whole imagery behind it and the
fact that Jason Bourne is you know he is
older now he's not like you know like
Matt Damon's not like old status but you
know he's like Jason Bourne from what he
has to do this he's aging he's like he's
kind of like Solid Snake I mean Metal
Gear Solid 4 well no I'm not even that
old no not even that old my one concern
from watching this trailer I felt like
they were going a little too Hollywood
destruction so I'm like the Bourne
movies have never been a bow like the
Crete like their car chase sequences are
you know they're totally like stuntmen
and stuff and they look [ __ ]
fantastic yeah there's like collisions
there and explosions there and whatnot
but yes know what I mean like when
there's a crashing through the casino
and Vegas it it just started it started
feeling a little too much like okay this
is this is feeling like Hollywood
familiar whatever I pull them all that
or I'm not the greatest at for me my
work
right now and do you Tommy Lee Jones
where's that guy been [ __ ] was he like
in no country for old men and he like
cameoed and men and like oh dude oh sick
addition to the group hope he's not like
just what I like what I'm seeing with
the Tommy Lee Jones character like the
Bourne movies always have that head
honcho who's like leading the search for
Jason Bourne and they're always like you
know dicks they're not people you like
but Tommy Lee Jones was a seem like a
I'm kind of like you you know I don't
know what you're up to but think you're
a cool cat and there's some like you
know Jason Bourne returning stuff like
well thank God I was like Jason Bourne
every movie there's someone freaking out
at the screen going that's Jason Bourne
I like that it's like they're doing
something different I feel like they're
telling like what could be a new like
trilogy in his life you know cuz actors
can always go for franchises and you see
like old action stars I couldn't kill it
man Liam Neeson Mel Gibson he's gonna be
an old action but he's gonna be in the
action star level he watched
Schwarzenegger Stallone even though I
hear he's retiring from acting I'm
telling you Matt Damon is gonna fit
right in with those guys anyway dudes if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject it
might be worth your time who knows
now you could follow me on Facebook the
real rejects Instagram at the greg alba
and twitter at the greg alba and also at
the real rejects and i want to give a
shout out to i don't know her actual
name but her instagram name is finding
molly now I noticed she following me
like a while ago and then I saw her
photos and Allah knows like it's like
followed her back and I figured she like
lived in like based off her bio that she
lives sounds sounds creepy based off her
bio this was in the UK so I just wanted
to say hi to her
and she had this photo where she was you
know wearing some Bat Man clothing and
she looked really good she looked really
good
finding Molly go look her up she could
you know give her some Follett's